got so in this lecture, I'm going to teach you how I personally use ABC strategy. See, the method
that I've taught you already, it works like a charm, okay? But if you apply the things I'm going to
teach you right now, your win rate is going to drastically increase, okay? But it requires a lot
of patience. And what I'm going to teach you are a plus ABC setups, okay? So this is how I would
personally approach ABC strategy. So first of all, I will look at the high time frame. So it
could be a four hour market structure, right? Or daily market structure. So if the four hour or
high time frame market structure is bullish, I am going to only look for long positions, okay?
And if the market structure, let's say is making lower, lower, high, lower, lower, high, lower,
then I'm only going to look for short positions. How? I want to see a pullback,
then another pullback. So an ABC, oh my god, bro.
So ABC within this leg right here, okay? And this leg, let me do this.
You want to draw out your fib, right? From this move to this move. And you want to look for ABC
setup formations above the 0.5 level, okay? Or I would say this is the like this right here.
So the mid part. So this is 0.5, right? So the 0.5. So the mid part above the 0.5 level.
And this is like the golden area where you can look for ABC setups, okay? But generally,
you can look for ABC setups above the 0.5 level. So when price comes back above the 0.5 level,
you can drop down. So let's assume that you are looking at the market structure on
four hour time frame. What you can do is you can drop down to 15 minute time frame.
And then you can look for an ABC setup right on a 15 minute above the 0.5 level. And the
C leg goes into some sort of a supply zone or a or an auto block, okay? Or it could be a fair
value gap. So the C leg goes into the fair value gap right here. And then you look, you look for
the ABC setup formation, okay? And you take your entry during kills on ours. So the kills on ours
would be from three, two, six, that is for London session. And for New York, it's going to be eight,
30, they'll 11, 15. That is New York time. So this right here is London session. And this is
and this is New York session. So your entry must be between these ours. Okay, that is a must. So
let me repeat this again. You have lower, lower, lower, high, lower, lower, high, lower, lower.
So you draw out your PD area, which is, you know, discount and premium zones. So you want to wait
for price to come back into premium zone, right, which is above the 0.5 level. And then you look
for ABC formation, the C leg goes into some sort of POI. It could be an auto block. It could be
fair value gap. And it could be, yeah. So to refine it, even further, what I do is when I have a POI
here, let's say on the 15 minute, right, what I would do is I would drop down to five minute and
refine that POI even more to make it smaller. Okay. So sometimes what can happen if you have
a 15 minute POI, price can sometimes do this and then hit the, you know, the refined OB on five
minute and then give you an ABC setup. So that is sometimes I do something that I do sometimes.
So this is how I personally approach ABC guys. First of all, look at the market structure.
And how do you look? So what you want to do is you want to look back 25 days. Okay. So in the last
25 days, if the market structure is making lower, lower, high, lower, lower, high. So in real market
conditions, let me delete this, the market structure is going to look something like this. Okay,
it's not going to be a clear downtrend. It's going to have movements like this. Okay,
it's not going to be clean. So as long as the price is going down, as long as it keeps going
down, you just look for short positions. And that is why this method requires a lot of patience,
guys. It requires higher timeframe, like four hour timeframe. Yeah, it could, you could use one
hour, but I do not recommend that. I mean, you can use ABC on any timeframe, except one minute.
We can use it on one minute as well, but I do not recommend that timeframe. Trust me, it's just not
okay. But see, the high timeframe is going to make you profitable. This is it. I'm telling
you guys, just build this patience to trade high timeframe, guys. I know, I know you want to see,
you want to get that dopamine hit when you are trading on like one minute and five minute and
you see your trades going to profits and you're like, wow, I'm making money. But that is a bad
habit. And you're going to get addicted to trading. And when you get addicted to trading,
you're going to take five to 10 trades per day, which is really, really bad guys. And you're going
to prevent straight and going to blow your account. So just stay away from that. And similarly, if
you're looking at a market structure that is bullish and the price is making high, high,
high, low, high, high, low, then you only have to look for long setups. So a long setup puts
look something like this. You would have a B C going into the sea, like going into some sort of
auto block, right? And you look for shift in market structure on a smaller timeframe,
like that. And you literally just take your entry, right? So I'll give you guys a couple of examples.
And then it's going to be clear guys. So here is example number one, as you can see for the
past month, we have been bullish, right? So we created this higher high. So we can expect higher
prices. So now this right here is our POI. And you can see price came here, tap to do this level.
And forcing the early buyers to like go long, but watch what happens. You have an ABC pattern.
Inside the POI, which is a nice thing, like it doesn't necessarily have to form inside the POI.
We only need to see the seal that go into here. But if this occurs, then it absolutely fine as
well. So let's go to the 15 minute timeframe to look for market structure shift. So as you can
see, there is no clear structure here. So in this scenario, what you can do is you can drop down to
five minute. Okay. And when you drop down to five minute, you can see that we have the structure.
So I want to see a body close above this level. So let's see what happens.
And I believe we do have a body close right here. So we look for extreme water block,
which is right here, as you can see, this right here. So I'm going to mark this out.
Okay, perfect. And I'm going to take my entry from this level. Probably put my stop just below
this low right here. And I would target one to two, but let's see how this goes.
So price comes back,
taps in, right, and just watch that move. It's crazy.
So price went ahead and took out this high right here.
So remember, we knew that we were bullish for the past month, right? And
you know, we took the straight right here and we targeted this low. So that is like prime
ABC, your take profit level was hit. And right after that, you have a reversal. So I'll give you
guys another example. All right, guys, so here is example number two. You can see we are bullish.
We had a breakout structure, identifying and showing us that the trend is to the upside.
The market structure is bullish. Okay, that's all you need to identify,
market structure guys and trends. So look at the last 20 or 30 days. And if the market is
making high highs, higher lows, higher highs, then that is plus point. Okay. So right here,
you can see we have this auto blog and we also have this volume and balanced right here.
So you can see that, let's remove this for now, let's consider auto block as our POI,
just for the sake of this example. So right here, you can see we have A, B, and C. The C leg
goes into our POI. So let's drop down to 15 minute timeframe. And let me show you how this goes.
I want to look for a shift in my, okay, so we have a market structure shift now.
So if I look at here, this is the first candle of the favorite gap, right? So this is our auto
block. I would take my long position just right here. I would put my stop below this low or this
low. So I would target the high of the B leg, which is this. So let's see how this plays out.
So we get a tap. Right. So let me do this.
Boom, a look at the power guys, one to 10 secured within
a couple hours, guys. That is how powerful it becomes when you are following the trend,
you're taking trades in the direction of the trend. And also you are using POIs with ABCs.
Okay. So and you're also using higher timeframe. Higher timeframe is the king guys. Just stay away
from low time frames. If you want to take trades like these, because when you're using higher
time frames, you're going to see moves like this. All right. So it's simple guys. Remember the rules,
we look at high timeframe market structure, right trend. After that, we mark out the premium
slash discount zones. Wait for price to come below slash above
0.5 level of fib. Wait for ABC for formation.
Below slash above 0.5 level. And the sea leg goes into that POI. Now, when I say that sea
leg must go into that POI, what can happen is the whole ABC setup can form in that POI. So it
doesn't necessarily have to be the sea leg. But if the ABC pattern occurs in that autoblock,
when you have like, let's suppose you have, you know, a POI marked out. And what can happen
sometimes this price going to touch this autoblock, push up and then create another an ABC pattern
inside the autoblock. Right. So it's going to look something like this. Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Simple as that. So I hope you guys enjoyed this video and this lecture. If you have any more
questions, you can ask them in the discord and I'll see you guys in the next video.